From subliminal imagery to dated stereotypes,
much has been written about details later
deemed inappropriate in kids films, but what
about the mature themes and jokes put their
intentionally for older audiences?
While these scenes may provide parents with
little chuckle or food for thought, they could
lead to some pretty awkward conversations
with their kids afterwards.
Here are 10 Inappropriate Scenes in Kids Movies
Zootopia
While Judy Hopps acts as if she’s above
corruption when investigating the missing
Otter in Zootopia, she uses several questionable
tactics to uncover the mystery.
Including but not limited to blackmailing
and coercing Nick, as well as colluding with
Zootopia’s organized crime element.
Judy’s ‘by the book’ persona goes out
the window completely when she has Mr. Big
threaten to ice Duke Weaselton in order to
scare some information out of him.
I guess the moral of this story is that the
ends justify the means.
Toy Story
As early as their first film, Pixar was slipping
in jokes that only older viewers would catch.
Did you ever notice the toy in Toy Story that’s
a clear allusion to the sex trade industry?
Of course this is in the deranged Sid’s
bedroom, seen when all of his mutilated toys
come out from under the bed.
There’s one that looks like a Barbie doll’s
legs attached onto a fishing line with a hook
on the end, literally turning her into a hooker.
Shrek
There’s a lot more that’s inappropriate
about Lord Farquaad than just his name.
Did you ever wonder what he was doing in his
bed when he asks the mirror to show him Princess
Fiona’s image again and again?
There’s even a subtle movement under his
covers when he take a peak for some reason.
Really the Mirror’s disgusted face says
it all.
Toy Story 3
One of the great things about Toy Story 3
was that it felt like it was made for fans
who grew up with the first film and were now
the same age as Andy as he headed off for
College.
The image of Woody’s friends joining hands
and accepting their impending incineration
recalls stories told about real-life tragedies.
This is easily one of Pixar’s most intensely
disturbing moments, thank god for THE CLAW
saving the day just as the toys had accepted
their fate.
Despicable Me 2
Even though Despicable Me 2 was only released
a few years ago, there’s one scene that
probably wouldn’t make it past censors today.
When Gru is having a bad date with the shallow,
annoying Shannon, Lucy saves him by shooting
Shannon in the rear with a mild moose tranquilizer.
While it’s obvious that Gru didn’t administer
the drugs himself, just having a date end
up drugged and in such a compromising position
is bad for business, even for a supervillain.
The Good Dinosaur
Considering that The Good Dinosaur seemed
to be more in line with Cars, in that it was
a Pixar film with very little adult appeal,
there was one scene that seemed particularly
out of place.
No, not the scene where Arlo’s father dies,
by now that’s par for the course in Disney
film, I’m talking about the scene the where
Arlo and Spot trip balls (hallucinate) on
some rotten fruit.
Their out of body experience looks like a
pretty fun time, despite the brief drug hangover.
Inside Out
As if Inside Out’s Riley doesn’t have
enough problems, it’s likely things could
actually get worse for the 11 year old.
Things got so bad in the film that she stole
her mom’s credit card, ran away and hopped
a bus to Minnesota.
While we see her finally adjusting to her
new home near the end, we can’t help but
think her world could be easily crushed again
if her dad ever finds out that her mom daydreams
of an ex boyfriend anytime she needs to go
to her happy place, implying she regrets her
choice in husbands.
Perhaps the sequel will be about Riley’s
emotions during her parents’ turbulent divorce.
Ghostbusters
In the 1980s the lines between kids movies
and adult fare was a little more blurred
than it is now.
For example you have a film like Ghostbusters,
a PG-13 movie with lots of mild swearing and
sexual innuendo, yet marketed towards kids
with toys and an animated series.
One scene in particular that shouldn’t make
any sense to younger viewers is as brief as
it is inappropriate.
We’re referring of course to the now infamous
felatio scene that implies Ray is receiving
oral sex from a ghost.
Don’t expect anything like this in this
summer’s reboot.
How To Train Your Dragon 2
This next entry isn’t so much inappropriate
as it is just an unexpected nod to a character’s
sexuality.
The world of How To Train Your Dragon is filled
with gruff vikings, so it may surprise you
to find out which character is actually gay.
In How To Train Your Dragon 2, Hiccup’s
parents reunite and start bickering right
away, causing Gobber to comment “This is
why I never married.
This and one other reason.”
That other reason could be anything, but actor
Craig Ferguson and director Dean Deblois have
both confirmed that Gobber just hasn’t found
the right man.
If anything, the line is a little too subtle,
perhaps How To Train Your Dragon 3 will contain
a more overt reference to Gobber’s sexuality.
Ice Age : Dawn of the Dinosaurs
In the third Ice Age film, Buck, the weasel
voiced by Simon Pegg, goes a little too far
when regaling the possums with stories.
Buck is about to tell them about the time
used a sharpened clam shell to turn a T-Rex
into a T-Rachel when the mammoths put an end
to fairy tale time.
Parents watching were probably very thankful
that Buck didn’t go into any more detail
about his crude castration of a dinosaur.
These are just a few of the jokes and references
that hopefully went over kid’s head, did
any go over ours?
Tell us what we missed in the comments below.